على الرغم من الاستبعاد الاوروبي لاي دور
صيني لتسويه في اوكرانيا الا ان للرئيس
الفرنسي رايا اخر فقد راى ايمانويل ماكرون
انه يمكن لبيكين ان تلعب دورا رئيسيا
لايجاد طريق يؤدي الى السلام في اوكرانيا
واضاف في مستهل زيارته للصين ان بكين
باقتراحها خطه سلام قد اظهرت اراده لتولي
مسؤوليه تجاه هذا الملف كما تابع امام
الجاليه الفرنسيه في العاصمه الصينيه ان
الخطه الصينيه يمكن لها ان تكون محاوله
لشق طريق يؤدي الى السلام لافتا الى ان
الحوار مع الصين ضروري حيث لا يمكن ترك
الساحه لروسيا ياتي الكلام الفرنسيه راويه
بعد اسبوع من استنكار غربي لاي دور صيني
بمبادره سلام في اوكرانيا بسبب موقفها
الداعم للروس فقد
اعترفيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي الاسبوع الماضي
ان الصين لا يمكن ان تكون وسيطا في الحرب
الدائره في اوكرانيا الانحيازها الكبير
الى رو سيا على حد وصفه الا ان مكرونه
الذي يسبح عكس التيار الاوروبي قد يجد
منفع اقتصاديه اذ يبحث الرجل عن علاقات
اقتصاديه متوازنه مع الصين على حد قوله
[موسيقى]